thank you so much for the very kind
introduction
one of the main drives during my PhD
which has been the question of how do we
keep autonomous systems in particular
robotic systems including drones so
driving cars home robots and even more
generally AI and automation systems safe
how do we keep these systems safe and
especially how do we keep them safe in a
world that is increasingly complex where
we're deploying these systems when they
have to interact with humans and what
does it even mean to have safety
assurances for these systems given that
there's so much uncertainty going on in
the world and how should this inform our
design of robotics so I'm going to be
giving you only some partial answers
which is the best I could get during my
PhD and also primarily living it with
some open questions so my goal at the
end of this talk is that you'll be quite
dissatisfied and hopefully a little
intrigued to keep looking into these
questions yourselves so as all of you
know robotic systems have really been
gaining applications in the last few
years and there's a lot of excitement
about still driving cars drones for a
variety of applications including
transportation of goods there's actually
rhetoric systems that are being deployed
for delivery right now on the Berkeley
campus I don't know if you have these
here at Stanford they're kind of
ridiculous but they sort of get from A
to B it's unclear how autonomous they
actually are and people sometimes have
fun kicking them around we're just an
interesting human robot interaction
problem but also you know applications
like manufacturing and surgery and the
truth is that this opens a lot of very
exciting opportunities which is why we
want to be able to deploy these systems
but at the same time we have a number of
important challenges and one of the most
important is how do we keep these
systems safe because traditionally when
we think about robotic systems as
they've have existed over the last few
decades this is how we've gone about
safety we just keep the robot in a cage
separated from humans and we slap
threatening sticker on it making sure
that
nobody gets near it or else this is what
will happen to you but you know as we
explore the possibilities of robotics
and we start deploying them on more open
environments where there is more
complexity and more uncertainty it
really becomes very difficult to
guarantee that these systems will be
able to to actually stay safe this is
video from the year that I spent in
industry before starting my PhD and as
you can see we were going about safety
with a rather rudimentary method it kind
of worked pretty effectively we want to
make sure that the drone wasn't going to
fly into the neighbor's house and it did
the trick but obviously it wasn't a very
principled method so when I started at
Berkley we started you know exploring
exciting applications also with drones
and so we had this system that was able
to fly following some safety algorithms
but every now and then we had something
like this happen which was quite quite
quite terrible if you're a grad student
and this happens to you you know that
the next couple of weeks are not going
to be a lot of fun and really what we
are you know at this point we were
really asking okay what can we do to
make sure that we can run experiments
for example running reinforcement
learning algorithms from our drones
without the risk of these things
happening and so we you know went back
to the drawing board my first proposal
was that we used ropes but that didn't
really fly so we went back to the
drawing board and we came up with some
theoretical safety guarantees that made
sure that whenever the drone came into a
situation where it was theoretically
predicted that it could hit the ground
or hit the ceiling we would actually
override it in a probably safe manner
now the problem with provably safe
guarantees and we're going to be talking
a lot about this in the next few minutes
is that they're they're only going to
work for as long as the reality that
you're dealing with has to do with the
model that you're using for it so we
decided to put this to a test by turning
on a big fan and starting blowing air
sideways how the quadrotor and what you
can see here is that when the system
comes back down and flies into this air
stream that it's not part of the
theoretical model that we based
occurrences on things actually start to
go a little bit wrong and eventually
the system is taken so far away from the
operating conditions that it was
assuming that as you can see the safety
guarantees no longer apply and it
actually hits the ground and this is
this was only more true when we started
trying to fly drones around humans so
here we have a little drone and supposed
to be navigating around human
pedestrians here we have our canonical
human being Sylvia who is also a grad
student at Berkeley and so what we found
was that whenever the human moved in a
way that was roughly following the
predictions made by the system then
everything went fine but when the human
did something unexpected like in this
case going around this coffee spill that
we drew on the floor
the drone gets confused doesn't know
what it's doing initially crashed into
Sylvia and of course you can see how
upset she is so at the end of the day
what we get from this is that sure we
can we can compute theoretical
guarantees and this is a good starting
point when we try to give assurances for
safety for our systems but ultimately
any guarantee that we're able to compute
and to reason about it's only as good as
a theoretical model that it is based on
and ultimately modeling error is
something that is inevitable whenever
you're dealing with a sufficiently
complicated system alternately a
sufficiently interesting system that
you'd like to do anything with it
and menu this is not only a problem that
we're having in a university lab if you
look at what's happening these days with
the prototypes that are being deployed
of self-driving cars this issue of
modeling error is a central problem in
trying to give safety assurances so in
these two examples you basically have
two cases where the ubirr car and the
Google car at the time were both unable
to predict where the human was going to
be and what the human was going to do at
a given point in time in the case in the
left human driver made a left turn the
robot wasn't even expecting there to be
a human there but they're there they
were and in the case in the right there
was a bus driver who thought it was
their turn to go and the car thought
that it was its turn to go on the ended
up on the same place at the same time so
really this notion of correctly
reasoning about the world and
acknowledging that your models can
sometimes be flawed is really important
when it comes to giving safety
guarantees now this is important and in
part and in fact it's
think that it's worrying more and more
people as we're starting to see these AI
and robotics technologies get deployed
and developed and if you look at
declarations made you know statements
made in the last year or two by
different governments you see things
like human beings will only be able to
confidently and fully reap the benefits
of AI systems if they can really trust
the technology which was stated by the
European Commission a couple years
earlier the United States White House
stated the public safety must be
protected as these technologies are
tested and begin to mature and only last
year the Deputy Secretary General with
Chinese Academy of Sciences said that to
truly harvest the benefits of AI we must
first ensure it's a cure-all and
reliable deployment so or development
and if you look really at the common
factors here you can see that trust
safety controllability security
reliability are quite pervasive in you
know even government concerns about AI
so what I'll try to convince you about
in the next few minutes is that if we
want to deploy high-stakes automated
systems with these robotic systems for
more general AI systems even you know
going as far as your Facebook ad
optimizer these systems really should be
able to reason about what kinds of
guarantees and assurances they can give
and how reliable these guarantees are in
light of the actual evidence that
they're getting from the world so how
much should I trust my guarantees given
that the world is not identical to my
model and so this is really a crucial
distinction that I think we really need
to make when thinking about safety
assurance it is one thing to give a
guarantee which is ultimately a
mathematical a formal statement about an
abstraction of the world which is a
model and it's not identical to the
world and giving an assurance understood
here as a high confidence statement
about the real system which is not the
same thing as the model and this can be
based on model guarantees you can have a
model you can make some statements about
the model but then you really need to
breach I need you to not refuse to
bridge this reality gap between the
model and the real system and so there's
ways in which we can do this and I will
be talking about them
today I'm going to be talking first
briefly about what it means to give
guarantees about a model of the system
so I'll be talking a little bit about
safety analysis and then three different
ways in which we can actually try to
give guarantees all right so let's start
with safety verification which is how to
give theoretical guarantees on the safer
for safe operation of a system model and
hereby safe we mean that we won't want
to make sure that we can avoid a certain
set of forbidden failure states what is
a failure state it can be anything from
an actual physical collision to the
robot violating some rule that we've
specified for it for example we might
decide that it's already a safety
violation for a self-driving car to be
driving in the wrong direction on the
road so the way we formalize this is
through dynamical systems theory so we
think of the state of the system which
can be the robot but also other
variables in the world like for example
the positions of other vehicles or other
agents and we reason about the evolution
of this state with some differential
equation and what we say is the
evolution of the state can be affected
it can depend on the state itself what
is already going on but also on some
decisions that we make the control input
and possibly on some other external
variables that we don't control and this
disturbance term can capture anything
from the actual actions of other agents
in the environment to in fact any form
of modeling error so if we're not sure
about what really is going to happen we
can capture this disturbance we can
capture this uncertainty about some
deformation disturbance input that can
really affect the evolution of the
dynamics so under those conditions we
can specify a set of forbidden or
failure States
and reason about whether the trajectory
of the system as it also over time will
at all times stay clear of these
obstacles now unfortunately what this
trajectory does or in some cases
fortunately will depend on the decisions
that we make over time therefore we're
not really just asking well the system
always be safe but rather is there
something that we can do with our
control in
put to keep the system safe at all times
here in general throughout the talk I'm
going to be using boldface to refer to
trajectories or signals over time and
regular font to mean the instantaneous
value of a certain control like control
action or state over time one way of
which we we can capture whether or not
the system is violating the constraints
is by using some form of metric for
example some distance some sign distance
that is positive when you're outside or
the failure states and negative when
you're inside it'll be all the more
negative the more deeply you violate the
constraints all the more positive the
more margin you have and so we can
reason for these two trajectories about
the evolution of this distance over time
or this margin and the first thing to
notice is that taking an average of this
margin or any sort of sum it's actually
inadequate if you look at the integral
of these two curves in both cases the
integral is positive however in one of
the cases the system is really violating
the constraints this is an important
point to make because a lot of the
optimal control formulations that are
out there including reinforcement
learning tend to reason about the sum of
rewards over time which is really
inadequate to capture something like the
worst case the minimum reached by the
function over time which is really what
we care about when we ask questions
about safety so instead we'd like to
reason about the minimum of L reached
over time and this is often called a
reach ability problem where ultimately
what we have is the minimum or the
infimum of the signal over time and long
story short we can reason about this and
we can obtain it through dynamic
programming for example propagating
things backward in time making the
optimal decision at every instant in
time I'm not going to get into all the
technical details of this but this is
generally stuff that you can find also
feel free to stick around at the end ask
me for references but if we do this for
the top trajectory we see that this is
okay it's a safe trajectory because the
minimum over time it's positive if we
propagate in a similar way through the
second trajectory we see that at some
point it becomes negative we keep this
minimum value as we propagate the value
function to the present and we see that
this is an unsafe trajectory because we
will eventually hit the
the unsafe or sorry the failure states
okay so that's the trajectory that we
don't want the way this actually works
when we go from individual trajectories
to the full analysis over the state
space is what's called hamilton-jacobi
safety analysis and we can visualize it
here suppose this is our much smaller
failure set we're going to now look at
it kind of in 3d we're going to have the
initial distance function which is a
cone in this case we're using euclidean
distance to the failure disk and then we
can propagate the dynamics of the system
backwards in time making the optimal
decisions and also considering the worst
case of the disturbance so that we're
protecting not only about some nominal
model but against all possible
realizations of our uncertainty and when
you end up with this propagation you can
see that the value function has sort of
lift out of the original cone and now
we're left with this boundary which is
what separates safe States from unsafe
States and so we have this important
notion of the safe set which is a set of
states from which the controller can
take some action that will keep the
system from entering the cone sorry from
entering in this case the disc for all
time if you're here if you're inside you
already have a negative value which
means that even under your best effort
there might be a realization of the
system that will actually drag you into
the cone so this this safety analysis is
actually very useful because it allows
us to obtain really the mathematically
best effort that we could possibly make
to keep the system safe which means that
it can often reveal some non-intuitive
strategies to keep safety that might not
be directly achievable by just having
some engineers sit down and hard code
them into the system so whenever we can
compute these solutions it's actually
extremely helpful and an example of this
was a project that we did with NASA a
few years ago where they wanted to be
able to have essentially an air traffic
management system that would scale
better than just having human
air-traffic controllers so that we could
have in the order of hundreds thousands
or tens of thousands of vehicles flying
in the same airspace for example over
the San Francisco Bay Area at the same
time
and the way we went about this was to
break down the system into sequential
planning for all the trajectories
because in fact NASA was going to have a
first-come-first-served system so what
they wanted to do was have the first
vehicle obtain the same trajectory then
the same tradition vehicle come in
request a trajectory and obtained
something I would be saved without
perturbing the trajectory already given
to the first vehicle and so on and so
forth
so what we were able to do was we
actually developed a new theoretical
tools for time varying safety analysis
and ultimately what this did was we
first took the first vehicle which was
the highest priority vehicle and we gave
it a trajectory by computing the safety
analysis here we see the safely
reachable set that we were talking about
earlier and then the first vehicle
becomes a moving obstacle for the second
vehicle and you see that it cuts into
the backward time propagation of the
second vehicle safe set and the same
thing happens here for the first two
vehicles becoming obstacles for the
third and the first three vehicles
becoming obstacles for the fourth so
when you run the safety computations the
advantage is that you can actually run
each one in the state space of a single
vehicle so that you don't get this
combinatorial blow-up that you would
normally get if you try to do all of the
vehicles at the same time and it turns
out that this scales linearly with the
number of vehicles because each time
you're only doing computation in the
space of that single vehicle and also it
gives you strict safety guarantees as
long as things are according to the
model and it also gives you the optimal
trajectories for these vehicles in the
sense of being the shortest the quickest
trajectories to get from A to B subject
to the priority ordering which is what
NASA is giving us so this is for for
vehicles but you don't have to take my
word for it that it works here it is in
a simulation with 50 vehicles flying
over San Francisco we have another one
with 200 vehicles over the Bay Area but
I think it's actually less interesting
what you can actually see here is
vehicles flying with different wind
conditions and different timing
conditions and you see that all of them
are actually able to compute their
trajectories and and complete them
without coming into collisions with one
another's with one another
the wind speed is important because
while we are taking this as a
theoretical safety guarantee in fact
this is something that will apply as
long as your error the error between the
model and the real system is bounded by
a difference in your in your evolution
of the of the position of the vehicle
that can be interpreted as wind speed of
up to 11 meters per second so this
doesn't necessarily mean it has to be
exactly one speed it could also be other
things like Gus it could be capturing
the delay in your system when it tries
to make a term but it actually takes a
while as long as it can be captured
under virtual wind speed of 11 meters
per second the guarantee actually
applies to the physical system and so
this is a nice segue into the next part
of the talk which is okay so we have
this your article guarantee how do we
how do we make sure that it actually
applies to the physical system or to
what extent can we make sure that it
applies to the physical system you can
argue that in fact there is no way to
make 100% sure because fundamentally and
model and reality are two different
things the model is a mathematical
object and then reality is something
made of atoms about which we can't
really write theoretical statements we
can make an abstraction of the reality
and then make theoretical statements
about that the reality is not it's a
type error right you can't have
theoretical guarantee about the physical
world all right but we can't do things
so one of the first things that we
wanted to do was see if we could apply
some learning based methods to to our
robotic systems and this is something
that is becoming more and more
attractive because learning based
methods like reinforcement learning you
can see a couple of examples over here
are becoming are being proven to be very
powerful at planning over long horizons
with complex dynamics multi-agent
systems at this is alpha star that was
released by a deep mind or at least
published by the mind very recently and
ultimately what all of these
reinforcement learning methods are doing
is they are finding in inferring some
structure about the dynamics of the
system and then computing good first
effort approximations to the solution of
an optimal control problem he
you see humanoid which is a high
dimensional dynamical system and it's
actually performing fairly well you know
over the irregular terrain jumping
around I've seen pretty well given that
it's not explicitly using a model of the
world however the problem with these
systems is that they are good at average
performance but sometimes they have
pretty pretty terrible worst-case
performance and it's very difficult to
come up with any sort of guarantees as
to when something like that is going to
happen and so the thing that we wanted
to do is sort of get over this this this
limitation and apply these kinds of
techniques to systems that can break and
cause damage like robotic systems so
here we have the issue that we were
talking about earlier which is if we
only reason and optimize an average
performance we're not really capturing
worst-case worst-case outcomes so how do
we go and apply these kinds of systems
or these types of techniques or to
robotic systems where a worst-case
outcome can actually be quite costly
well we can actually use the safety
analysis and the structure that comes
out of the safety now this is to provide
some very nice properties around the
learning system so it turns out that you
can use the safety analysis to provide
what's called a safety envelope that
will that will basically treat the safe
set as a safety bubble within which you
can do whatever you want and then when
you reach the boundary of the safety
bubble you'll need to take the safety
action to stay inside of it so here's
how it works here we have our robotic
system that's the ceiling the floor and
I'm plotting vertical position on the
vertical axis and then velocity on the
horizontal axis so basically the more to
the left you are the faster you're
moving down the more to the right you
are the faster you're moving up and so
in this picture with this relatively
simple dynamics model where you are
controlling the acceleration with your
rotor thrust you can actually compute
these sort of parabolic curves that tell
you that you're unsafe if you're near
the ceiling and moving up very fast and
also if you're near the floor moving
down very fast and you're safe if you're
somewhere in the middle well the next
hearing that we have as I was saying
informally is that if you start in n
stayed inside of the safe set then you
actually have a control invariant set
when you get to the boundary you're
applying the safe action you do whatever
you want on the inside you get to the
boundary again and you apply the safe
action and that is guaranteed to push
you back in as long as the amount of
mortal error that you have is contained
by some initial worst case bound that
you had pre computed or pre estimated so
the way this works in practice
is we have for example the autonomous
quadrotor here flying with some vikon
system and we're going to try to do some
simple reinforcement learning algorithm
but here the catch is that we're going
to initialize all the feature weights to
zero so what happens here is that we're
going to start with a really really bad
guess as to how to fly the quadrotor now
normally if we just let the quadrotor
fly under these conditions what is going
to do is it's going to crash into the
ground fortunately this is know what
happens because we have the quadrotor
inside of the safety envelope so
whenever the learning algorithm tries to
crash the quadrotor the safety override
says no you don't and takes over and so
we're first for the first few seconds
you can see that the learning algorithm
doesn't have very good ideas but after
about 30 seconds or so it starts
figuring out what it needs to do the fly
and it ends up flying up and down
following this trajectory reference that
we were giving it
so here the remarkable thing is know
that we're beating performance and
learning systems try anything like that
but rather that we're able to do this
with a system with a learning algorithm
that initially had a really really poor
idea of what to do and still we never
crashed we never ended up having to end
the experiment because the court culture
broke now of course the limitation here
is what happens when you add the fan
what happens when your model guarantees
are actually not accurate anymore and so
we are really back to this picture of
the mind of the mind the gap we have
some guarantees based on Newton's second
law and first principles models we have
the safety envelope protection but we're
not really accounting for for example
strong wind coupling between the
vertical and the lateral dynamics or any
other form of external perturbations
that we that we just forgot to model
right like for example the ground effect
so the way we are one way in which we
can get around this is it turns out that
the structure of safety analysis
gives us much more than just this one
layer of protection in fact it turns out
that we can replace a zero here by any
alpha greater than zero and it turns out
that the safety policy renders any level
set of the value function that is above
zero so any of these nested sets
controlled invariant which means that
rather than just a safety set or a
safety bubble what we have can be
thought of as a safety onion so what we
can do is we can use safety analysis to
compute the value function and therefore
all of the layers of this onion and then
use the data that we obtain as we are
exploring the world to gauge how much we
should trust the system and at what
point we're at a at a point where it
might be that outer layers of the onion
won't actually be trustworthy because
the model might be wrong at the outer
layers as long as the model is right at
a single layer we can use that layer to
protect ourselves and so basically this
is the approach that we follow I won't
get into the details of how we reason
about you know when the model is right
or wrong there's a variety of models
that you can use for that you can use
the calcium process you can use some
other form of anomaly detection but what
matters here is that when the quadrotor
comes down there's the same video that
you saw before but kind of zoomed out it
actually realizes that the model it's
actually not trustworthy so you're gonna
see two possible futures the the one
that's ghosted is the one that you saw
initially where the system is blindly
trusting its model-based guarantees the
second one you can see that very quickly
it realized that its model was not
trustworthy so it's saying I'm not gonna
use these layers of the onion because I
don't trust them I'm going to stay at
this height and I won't go down until
and unless I start getting new data that
tells me that it's actually safe to fly
in that region or it leaves that my
model is sufficiently accurate in that
region that I can trust my safety
analysis and so let me just say for time
okay very good and so the reason that
this is interesting and that I think
it's a good technique to have in general
is that it doesn't matter how good our
models are at the end of the day we're
always going to
some discrepancy between the model and
reality and any safety guarantee that we
have that is strictly based on the model
can eventually be broken by reality and
the real world is really good at making
fun of us and our best efforts so one
thing that we can do to make the system
a bit more resilient is to have it
actively monitor this reality gap
between its model and its mobile base
guarantees and what's actually going on
in the world and it turns out and this
is also important that we don't need the
model to be correct everywhere we just
need it to be sufficiently correct for
our guarantees to apply in an
intelligent way so if we have the system
plan incorporating the possibility that
its model might be wrong either now or
in the future then it automatically
becomes much more robust to model error
and so this is a general principle that
can be exploited in different ways and
so what I'm going to show you now is how
could we apply this to in particular the
interaction between robots and people
sure you could take people and say okay
the person has a disturbance I don't
know what they're gonna do I'm gonna do
some worst-case analysis where the
person could go in any direction and you
would get something probably you would
get overly conservative behavior and it
turns out that people while they are
extremely difficult to model accurately
actually follow very structured behavior
a lot of the time and cognitive science
over the last few years has given us
very powerful tools with which we can
attempt to model with a reasonable
degree of accuracy what people might or
might not do in certain contexts now the
interaction between humans and robots is
actually very tricky and historically
there's been cases where it's been great
to have the human and cases where it's
been quite tragic to have the human so
it's to me interesting that both of
these accidents happen in 2009 there's
one that's usually known as The Miracle
on the Hudson and now it has a movie
about it that some of you might have
seen it's called Sully it's got Tom
Hanks in it playing the the main pilot
and ultimately what happened was that
the plane took off and there's something
that we can talk a little bit more about
in
maybe in the discussion after the talk
and something very unusual happened
which was that both of the engines got
taken down by Bert strikes now when we
design an airplane we often assume that
it's extremely unlikely that both
engines are going to get taken down it
turns out that if the bird strike you
know if there's a sufficiently large
group of birds it's not impossible that
both of your engines will get taken down
and this is exactly what happened
thanks to their being a human pilot here
human judgment was the the key the key
factor in realizing that none of the
nearby airports were safely reachable
but you could safely land in the river
and so this is what the pilot did and
everyone on board got saved in the same
year unfortunately there was a tragic
case of the interaction between the
human autumn and the automation leading
to a crash this was an Air France Air
France flight that was flying from
Brazil to France over the Atlantic a
fairly non critical failure happened
where the pitot tubes was which measure
the airspeed of the aircraft got frozen
and so the auto pilot said hey I'm
confused I don't know what's happening
you take over and then the pilots were
very confused as to what was happening
the error message was extremely long
they thought that the plane might be
stalling and that the speed was very low
because the pitot tubes were frozen and
therefore reported reporting very low
speeds so they actually started speeding
up they increased a Siraj the plane
started climbing and eventually it
entered a stole and then the stall
warning went out but the pilots weren't
trusting the stall warning because at
this point they weren't trusting the
sensors and eventually three minutes
after the original failure the year the
aircraft crashed after what was
initially a pretty trivial failure of
the pilots had just kept flying they
would have reached Paris safely so here
the you know the lesson is that we
really have to be careful about how we
design the automation because it should
really be accounting for how humans are
going to interact with it and this can
often be very hard to model I don't know
if you have been following the case of
the Boeing 330 so yeah 737 max but it's
been it's been possibly the the most
you know the the biggest crisis that
Boeing has gone through at least in
recent decades and it has to do with
precisely a safety system interacting in
the wrong way with the crew making wrong
decisions but then making wrong
assumptions about how the crew was going
to respond to it and it's you know
already cost hundreds of lives
fortunately these planes are now
grounded so it's you know you can fly
safely but it's really something that is
it's getting Boeing to really rethink
how they're going about their safety
analysis so anyway I want to show you
this little example this project that we
ran where we had this drone flying
around the human and what is at least
one possible way in which you can reason
about safety accounting for how much you
should trust your mall of the of the
human so in the last few years there's
been and in fact in the last few decades
there's been a model that's been very
successful and very useful of for
predicting human actions which is what's
called a noisy rational human model or a
soft knacks model sometimes people call
it the loose choice rule because it was
introduced in originally by mathematical
psychology and econometrics in the 50s
and it's really found a lot of useful
applications in robotics and in
artificial intelligence and so what this
model does is it says well I don't know
exactly what the human is going to do at
any given point in time but what I can
tell you is that there are certain
things that are more likely than others
and how the robot reason is about the
likelihood of different actions is by
looking at how efficient each action
seems to be for the certain thing that
the human might want to do so the robot
has some utility based model of the
human objectives and so it says if it
looks like the human for example is
trying to walk to the door here we have
theta parameterizing what the human
might want to do say that Thea is leave
the room then the human is more likely
to walk towards the door a little less
likely to walk to walk indirectly
towards the door and very unlikely to
walk in the opposite direction so these
models work fairly well and the robot
for example can use them to navigate
around the human now the problem comes
when the human starts walking towards
the door and then suddenly something
happens that was no part of the model at
all in the first place for example
Herbie flies into the room the robot
probably can't even sense the presence
of the bee but if it could it probably
doesn't really understand
the very peculiar relationship that
people have with bees and therefore this
is a completely unexpected
you know reaction of the human and so
what can we do given that people will
sometimes do things that are unexpected
and they might violate all our
assumptions about them well we did a
little experiment in the lab it's
complicated to do experiments with bees
so instead we had coffee spill and then
again it wasn't even a real coffee spill
but here's the figure of coffee spill
and we can see that when the human
deviates what is happening here and I'll
play this video again is that the
prediction that we had of the human
going towards the goal is actually no
longer accurate so let me go back here a
couple of steps so you can see that even
though the human is deviating because
there's this coffee spill over there the
predictions still say no now the humans
gotta go straight to the goal and
eventually the robot gets to this point
where the trajectory isn't feasible and
it doesn't know what to do now of course
you could you know you could have
something better than this you could
have a last resort kind of like physics
based avoidance mechanism but really
here the point that we're trying to make
is that the predictions are wrong and
the predictions may be wrong can get you
in trouble in the best case you will
have to give the robot some sort of like
emergency avoidance maneuver and this of
course works if it's a little drone but
if you're talking about a car on the
highway you can already be in a lot of
trouble because you made the wrong
prediction so here the main principle
that we're trying to to apply is well if
the human is not following the model it
doesn't make sense to get mad at the
human for not following the model but it
makes sense to be a little bit more
skeptical about the model that we have
and ultimately by the way this is true
of any model you can have a very simple
kind of like model we sell the human
might want to do one of three things and
there's how they go about it or you
could have an extremely complex neural
network based model where you've
observed a million humans in rooms like
these and you've generalized and it
works very well 99% of the time but
there's always this tail of the
distribution that you have to be very
careful with because there can always be
something that you're not capturing and
in the case of humans I probably don't
need to convince you that this is true
that even if you train a neural network
and it's a very good neural network with
millions of neurons it's not really
going to capture everything that we do
so how do we go about
suspecting the model here we have the
human the goal-driven behavior of the
human and we have some noise irrational
model or some probabilistic model of
what he was going to do but ultimately
B's coffee spills any sort of unmodeled
intent or circumstances can really
violate all of our assumptions well it
turns out that in the models and the
reason about actions probabilistically
there are usually parameters that are
very helpful in in in modulating the
spread of the distribution so to speak
in the case of noise irrationality the
entropy of the distribution is directly
regulated by this beta parameter so the
higher the the beta parameter which is
often called rationality the rationality
coefficient I think rather incorrectly
because it's like you're blaming the
human whenever they don't follow the
model you become just being irrational
you can think of it as the degree of
confidence that you should have in the
model so when beta is very high you
should expect actions to
probabilistically concentrate a lot
around the optimal ones
whereas when beta is very low you should
expect things to be a little bit more
noisy and the human to with the
relatively high probability take actions
that are not actually that efficient for
the goal because a human is actually
doing something else that your goal is
not really capturing very well so what
we do is instead of treating it as a
fixed parameter which is how it's
usually treated we say okay why don't we
reason about this parameter beta under a
Bayesian framework so we think of it as
a hidden state that can change over time
meaning that my model can worked very
well for a while and then certainly
degrade relatively quickly when the bee
flies into the room and so whenever
something happens that we're not
expecting the robot can now reason about
the posterior distribution of this
confidence parameter given the prior
distribution that we had a moment ago
and then how probable is that the human
would take this action if this parameter
had high value versus if it had a low
value so we can actually do this update
because it's a scalar parameter we can
actually do this even numerically very
quickly over time and we can do it in
real time and so what happens is the
robot very quickly updates this
distribution about what the human is
likely to do
so when the human is not acting
according to your model your
distribution becomes much more cloudy
and uncertain and as a result of the
robot becomes more conservative and
avoids getting into big trouble with the
human now a question that is that is
legitimate it's can we how do we you
know combine this probabilistic notion
of how the human is going to move with
some worst-case analysis about for
example when we were talking about the
dynamics of the quadrotor before having
some sort of bounded disturbance about
that you know the physics of the robot
are not exactly this particular model
but there's only going to be this much
ground effect or delay in your rotor lag
well it turns out that a thing that you
can do is you can actually put the two
together and say I'm going to reason
about where the robot should be at a
given point in time but in practice I'm
going to reason about where the human
might be at a given point in time in
practice the robot it's not exactly
going to be at this point but I can
actually compute using safety analysis a
worst-case tracking error bound for
where the robot will be now there's
different ways you can do that this
reach ability based model there's
actually another method that professor
Provo and Marco where are you oh and
some of his students have been working
on which also gives you some some bounce
on the on the amount of error that
you're going to have when you track if
you use any of these methods what you
can now do is you can say well okay the
robot can be in any of these locations
over time
let me project this said onto the
probability distribution of where the
human might be over time and when I
integrate the amount of probability mass
that I have inside of this set that is
essentially the probability of crashing
into the human given the worst-case
tracking errors that I could have for
the fiscal motion of the of the vehicle
and when you combine these two
techniques it turns out that you can
actually provide some real-time
assurances about how likely the
quadrotor is going to be to stay clear
of the human whenever you are trying to
physically track these trajectories and
so what's good about this is that if the
human starts behaving in a strange way
this distribution will automatically
become much more blurry and so your
automatic computation of these
trajectories will automatically become
more conservative so here's a little
example we have the human moving around
like this this in this case we're going
to keep confidence fixed so we're not
actually reasoning about how well the
model is performing you can see that the
human goes to the first known goal
everything's fine
starts moving to the second known goal
and the model is able to make sense of
it and now the human starts moving in a
to a third goal that we have no idea
about and you can see that the
predictions are ridiculous they're just
not doing anything useful the robot is
convinced that the human is going to
turn around immediately and start going
to this goal because it doesn't realize
that the human is no longer following
the model in a reasonable way now
there's a relatively simple model but
even if we had a more complex model
ultimately this thing is qualitatively
what is going to happen your model will
make wrong predictions and still those
predictions even if they are
probabilistic will be overly confident
because you're not reasoning about
whether or not you should trust your
model instead with the Bayesian
confidence method that we're using here
you'll see a very similar behavior for
as long as the human is going to one of
the known goals but as soon as the human
starts moving to the third goal and this
is in fact the same recorded trajectory
of the human you can see that suddenly
you have a much more uncertain
prediction and so the robot decides to
take a more conservative path so that
even though the human is doing strange
things that the model doesn't understand
there won't be a collision so you're
kind of modulating the amount of
conservative that conservativeness that
you need your robot to exercise based on
how confused it is about what the human
is doing ok very good I'll just show you
a final video of the of the end result
this was actually short by Wired who are
much better than us at making cool video
so I just wanted to show you because
it's very nice you can see exactly
what's happening
as soon as Andrea starts deviating from
the behavior that you can expect you see
that the robot is already maneuvering to
stay clear of her and indeed gets out of
the way and avoids collisions even
though it doesn't exactly know what
she's going to do it's becoming more
conservative the second it realizes that
its model is not really being very good
at predicting alright but there's
probably one I don't know I have this
video twice there's probably one
you know there's kind of an elephant in
the room in this whole analysis that
we're doing and some of you might be
thinking about it which is okay but what
about interaction the human here appears
to just be doing its thing her thing and
the robot is actually getting in the way
isn't that going to affect what the
human does and indeed this is a very
important question that we're kind of
overlooking in that in that work and
it's extremely important in things like
autonomous driving and you know robots
in the home which is well the robot is
thinking about what the human is going
to do but the human souls are thinking
about what the robot is going to do
therefore the model of the robot should
really have you know the little bubble
inside there where the human is thinking
back about what the robot is doing and
this is also true of the you know of the
humans model of the robot so now this
kind of gets you into this sort of
infinite regress where the human is
thinking about what the robot think that
is you know that is thinking the robots
gonna think it's thinking and
unfortunately this becomes very
intractable very quickly and even you
know the companies deploying
self-driving car systems are trying to
issue this kind of treatment as much as
possible but what you can see is that
when you just try to assume that people
are doing their thing you can become way
way too conservative and so this is a
video I'll play it again it came out
last year some person on Twitter this is
the Hawaii mo vehicle trying to merge
onto a highway that sure has some
traffic but it's not terrible and it
just can't find an opening because it's
you know convinced that nobody is going
to let it go and eventually emerge
yourself obviously in order to be able
to drive competently you need to be
actively reasoning about how people are
going to respond to you and this is how
all of us who at least have driver's
license reason we're where we were
driving right so we really need these
systems to be able to do this
competently but also without being
overly aggressive and just saying like
well I'm just gonna do it and you have
to let me go so coordination here is
ultimately very important by the way
people are much better at coordination
than we typically realize there's a
little experiment that I like to run
because it's actually at least it
surprised me a lot when somebody told me
this the first time so we're gonna play
a very quick game which is basically
heads or tails but we're actually not
playing against each other we're playing
all together
so the objective is to say the same
thing as everybody else so basically I'm
going to count to three after three
we're all going to say either heads or
tails and we win if everybody says the
same thing and we lose it you know
people start saying different things
that make sense and we can't talk to
each other no winking no nothing okay
so we're going to go out to three I'm
gonna say one two three yeah and the
area is gonna be the answer okay already
all right let's do it
one two three heads okay
95% hints something like that okay very
good so what happens here is that you're
going we don't have time to get into the
whole details but every person is making
you know some quick and first about our
people slightly more likely to say one
thing than the other okay maybe heads
wait if I'm thinking this and everyone
is thinking this then we're totally all
going to say heads okay let's say heads
so this is very subtle and it's very
difficult for robots to reason about it
but still this kind of thing plays an
important part every time we're
negotiating an intersection so what one
of the things that I've been trying to
look at it's can we use game theory to
try to reason about this sort of
interplay between what I think you're
gonna do and what I'm going to do based
on what you're trying to make me do etc
it turns out that there are game
theoretic tools that you can apply
without you know thanks blowing up and
becoming intractable sorry and so one of
the one of the things that you can do is
you can have this tactical level at
which you're reasoning about
trajectories and you can have a
relatively simple interaction model
where for example you assume that their
human is going to respond to what you do
but they're not necessarily also
strategically trying to affect what
you're doing and that's fine over a
short horizon of about half a second so
you know the typical trajectory
optimizers tend to reason in this this
kind of level but if you're trying to
plan a complex maneuver like an you know
crossing an intersection or an
overtaking maneuver or reasoning about
who goes first before overtaking a truck
you really need to reason on a longer
horizon say five or ten seconds and so
when when you're using when you're
reasoning over that kind of horizon it
actually becomes very relevant to think
about how we're going to strategically
influence each other and so for that you
need to use something
that is more coupled where your
decisions and the decisions of others
are coupled and that is dynamic game
theory and so what we do to keep things
strength able in this case as we say
okay let's do a hierarchical analysis
where we use the full dynamical model
here with a simplified interaction model
and then at a high level we use a
simplified dynamical model where we
don't have all that you know all the
details of the tire in contact with the
ground and whatnot but instead we're
going to have a more accurate
interaction model between the automation
and the human again using some human
model that might be flawed and so the
way this works for the strategic planner
to give you a very quick picture you
don't need to look at the algorithm too
much as we consider we discretize the
world into a number of states and we
consider how much the human and the
robot like each of these states the
robot here is in yellow and we say okay
if you go one step back in time and you
consider each of these states for
example this one the robot has a bunch
of different actions that it can take
and based on the action that it takes
the human will be more or less happy
with the situation and will be more or
less happy to take different actions so
you're now reasoning probabilistically
as before about how the human might
respond to each of the possible actions
that you could take and so you say well
actually don't like this very much let
me try a different action see how the
human might respond probabilistically
and by doing this you determine the best
action that the robot should take at
each particular state at each point in
time and you can continue doing this for
all the states and then you can do this
in backward time it turns out that this
row over here can be done simultaneously
so you can actually exploit massively
parallel architectures so you can
actually do this whole computation very
quickly for a time horizon and because
we have a relatively simplified model of
the world you can actually have this
thing compute a value function for you
which is based on the game theoretic
interaction and what you can do now is
you say okay here's my trajectory
optimization that I'm using with my
standard method that may be Google or
way mo or uber are utilizing in their in
their planning so here in my
trajectories and here the human
trajectories and what you do now is you
add
a final value a terminal value term
terminal reward that captures the
strategic value so this is similar to
what you do if you're playing a game of
chess and you do some tree exploration
and then ultimately you use a heuristic
to determine what you think is going to
happen from now on and so it turns out
that by doing this you get an Augmented
version of the trajectory optimization
where you're actually saying well where
do I want to end up at the end of my
half second horizon where is the
interaction going to be more beneficial
to me we're using a model of this
interaction that is accounting for the
strategic influence between the two
players and it turns out that the - this
actually works fairly well and I want to
show you a couple of examples so in the
first case here we have an overtaking
maneuver and what you're seeing over
here is you know a color coding of the
values that the robot sees relates it to
the human so blue is high and read it
slow excuse me and as you can see when
the robot approaches the human there's a
list a tiny blue stain over here that
it's actually going to start growing and
the reason that it that it is there are
that it's growing is that the robot
nodes are there some it has some ability
to push the human to influence a human
to incentivize the lane change so in the
right case the human changes lane in the
left case she doesn't and what you can
see is that there's a gradient of value
pulling the robot sucking the robot into
the maneuver because even though it's
only planning with a short time horizon
which is what you can see here with the
little transparent cars I'll tell you
this review again the value is actually
already giving you the value the value
function here shown in colors it's
already giving you information about how
the interaction is going to go when you
go forward so here you actually make the
human move and then the value extends
over here here you just switch because
you have this blue carpet that it's
pulling you effectively like a potential
field into the overtaking maneuver so
it's a nice and tractable way of
reasoning with the longer horizon but
also doing this accounting for the
interaction now interestingly I don't
have a video for this as the confidence
that you have on the human goes down so
say that you're doing something like
what we were doing before and you're
saying hey the human is acting in a
strange way and it's wiggling around
when the confidence goes down the human
becomes more likely to do
anything that is not following your
model and then this value actually
becomes much less pronounced and in fact
it gets to the point where it becomes
unsafe to attempt an overtaking maneuver
and the robot will actually stay back
and avoid getting close to the human
because it doesn't understand what the
human is going to do so that's sort of
the kind of behavior that you would
intuitively expect now another example
that we really wanted to to cover and
with this I'm almost out of time was
what happens when you're getting to this
typical situation where you're going to
overtake a truck and then out of the
corner of your eye you catch somebody
who is accelerating on the other lane
and they're about to Tory cut cut you of
right the second before you ever take
the truck right this is probably
something that's happened to many of us
at some point in time well this is a
very game theoretic kind of situation
right you sort of feel the the game
theoretic pressure here in the test
where you're like well ok I can
accelerate and cut the other person off
and make it clear that they can't go or
I can decelerate and let them go with a
little bit of margin or I can keep doing
what I'm doing and maintain speed but
then they're probably still going to go
for it and it's probably not going to be
safe so it turns out that when you throw
this kind of analysis in this case
you'll see that the white car here
decides to slow down and let the yellow
car go in this case it actually starts
accelerating and decides that it's not
going to let the yellow car go and this
basically changes with the initial
conditions depending on who's going
faster and how far away you are from the
from the truck but it's interesting that
basically these two kinds of strategies
do in fact emerge where the in this case
the white car is really trying to affect
the behavior of the of the aggressive
car whether or not it takes any weight
so I wanted to end with a quick
reflection about you know we've been
talking about robotic systems but the
truth is that AI systems are you know
more and more pervasive and not only in
the form of robots but also in the form
of a lot of complex platforms that we're
interacting with every day and that
usually have this very simple model
where they assume that this is us and
this is them and all they're doing is
they're providing services once as a
one-time thing and they're really
failing to acknowledge that there is a
closed-loop dynamic between us and the
system and you know every time you give
a recommendation
this affects the opinions that the
person has it affects a new input that
the person gives you and every time you
give them you know recommendations
sometimes false positives negatives or
you favor a certain kind of content over
other kind of content this really
effects it changes the way the person is
thinking of the way the person is
interacting with the model I'm sorry
with the automation which in turns in
turn affects the model that the
automation is forming off the person and
so there I think there are some
important and kind of overlooked effects
at least from the technical point of
view and people are starting to talk
about this in the news about social
polarization through social media etc
but I really think that there's you know
here there's an opportunity to try to
analyze how this all works
but unfortunately an important thing to
realize is that this becomes very
intractable very quickly now the effects
that this thing is having on every human
are actually also having effects
globally on you know political
polarization social inequality and so
it's very hard to do but I really think
that we should make an effort to reason
about the closed loop between automation
systems AI systems and people and really
trying to reason about what are the what
are the consequences of these
interactions and to what extent we can
try to design systems that will prevent
certain kinds of damage that is
undesired in the interest of time I'm
going to skip a couple of slides that I
had in the end the at the very end I do
want to say that a couple of assumptions
that break that break a lot are
assumptions made by some companies
commercializing semi automated vehicles
for example the assumption that the
person will take over whenever the
system makes a mistake and that the
person will be able to take over in less
than a second to save their own lives
this is something that sometimes it's
true like this person here who grabs the
wheel right before the car autonomously
drives into the vehicle in the oncoming
lane but sometimes it's not true and
there have been accidents precisely due
to this failure to acknowledge that the
interaction between the human and the
and the robot is simply not that easy
and not that ideal and you know in the
case of the mcat system I really think
that bowing is learning the lesson the
hard way that it's not ok to just assume
that the pilot will immediately take
over especially when like in their case
they didn't even educate the pilots
about the existence of this system in
the first place
so with that you know a quick final
reflection I think we can make these
robotic and AI sisters more reliable in
the future and I think that some things
we can do is actively reason about how
we can uphold these assurances and these
guarantees monitoring the validity of
the assumptions that we make enlighten
the observed in light of the observed
data and remaining humble especially
when predicting human behavior and
trying to even figure out what human
values are and what humans want the
automation system to do which is I think
relevant to discussing things like you
know social media automation etc and
finally I think that one of the reasons
that this kind of safety analysis is
very useful and can be useful going
forward is that it really helps us think
hard and flesh out what are the
assumptions that we're making and what
are the conditions under which we think
it's acceptable for a system to fail
maybe society accepts that if both
engines get taken down by birds at the
same time the plane might go down and
maybe that is just ok that I'm not sure
we accept that one thing that we
certainly accept is that if both pilots
on a plane have a heart attack at
exactly the same time then the systems
gonna go down and we get on planes every
no everyday you know pretty pretty often
many of us and we're kind of implicitly
accepting that if both pilots die or
become incapacitated at the same time we
might really be in trouble we just think
that this is extremely unlikely and that
if this were to happen you know we sort
of make peace with the fact that that
this is a possible failure now so
fleshing out what are these assumptions
what are the conditions under which a
system might fail I think can be
extremely useful in terms of deploying
automation systems that even if they're
not perfect are highly reliable when
they're supposed to be reliable I'd much
rather get in a car that tells me this
car is going to drive safely unless you
it gets attacked at the same time by the
person to the right to the person to the
left and the person in front and it
doesn't have a way out then just getting
in a card that says this car is saved
99.9 percent of the time period right so
I mean maybe something to think about
when it comes to designing these kinds
of systems I think that if we get these
things right we will be able to have a
future in which all of our automated
systems will be so trustworthy that will
be perfectly okay with letting our
children go outside and play with them
but really in order to get from here to
that future we should very much mind the
gap so with that thank you very much I'm
happy to take any questions
all right yes right so that's very that
is a very good question and in fact what
I would argue is that you should always
be recomputing your model of what the
human is going to do but also know that
this is not sufficient because when you
are recomputing them all of what the
human is going to do you're going to do
this within some space of possible
models right and the problem is that
this space of models is fundamentally
what might not contain reality and so
you might improve the model but that
model might still not be able to capture
what the human is actually doing and
what the human is really going to do so
in fact what happens is you always have
an uncertainty region around the human
all you're doing with this with this
adaptation if you will is you're
changing the shape of that uncertainty
but even when the human is behaving
pretty accurately according to your
model you do have an ax certainly we
region around the human and it should
always be that way I think the the most
dangerous thing that a robot or an
automated system can ever do is to have
a perfectly clear-cut prediction of what
the humans going to do right that can
that is always going to end up
tragically sooner or later